hello everyone today we're looking at
bird pre-training of deep bi-directional
transformers for language understanding
by Jacob Devlin and then why Chung
Kenton Lee Cristina Tata Nova these are
people from Google AI language
so you're about to see the most hyped
model currently so basically Bert is a
model that takes as an input language
sub token sequences and outputs various
things so it can it can be made to do
various things almost any NLP tasks with
basically little training because the
Bert model comes pre trained on a very
large corpus and we're gonna see how
that's done all right
so the paper introduces basically the
kind of current state of the art of
language models and they say okay what
they want to do new is they want to do
bi-directional training I'm going to go
down here and see their comparison right
so here they compare three models and
these are representative of three types
of models so first here is for example
the the open AI transformer so this is a
this is the classic or one of the
classic transformer models we've talked
about transformers before and the
attention is all you need video so what
a transformer does is it uses attention
and if for those who forgot what
attention is if you have like a token
sequence ABCDE then a classic model to
use that would be an LST M so the other
stem would go here it would like have a
vector representation a hidden state and
then it would take this a it would take
this hidden state and compute a new
hidden state and then it will go on and
take
be and incorporate this into the hidden
state the hidden state kind of always
stays the same size but the the
recurrent model will update the hidden
state as it goes over the input sequence
so this is one way of dealing with
language but people have kind of done
another way and that's the attention
based mechanism is where basically for
each of these you compute a compute a
vector independently of each other so
each one has a vector representation and
then you have a vector representation of
what you of what you want which is
called an attention head and you can
have multiple of these but in the
simplest case let's just say we are
looking for the subject in this sentence
ABCDE is a sentence and one of the words
is the subject of the sentence then we
could have a vector here that's called a
query rec vector so these are called
these are called values V and this is
called a query Q and then these vectors
are the same size report at this
you're gonna compute the inner product
with each of these so the inner product
you wanna you wanna do okay I already
screwed this up
you're actually computing two vectors
for each token so honesty but this is
this is not too important for this step
one is the key and one is the value all
right value and this is called the key
and you have your query Q and you
compute the inner products actually with
the key sorry values aren't too
important for what I want to demonstrate
but you compute key with query all right
and that gives you basically for each
key it's gonna give you an output and so
you're gonna have you're gonna have a
for this ABCDE you're gonna have like
this much inner product this much inner
product this much this much this much
inner product so after maybe the softmax
you have like a nice distribution and
then you can say AHA here this is the
the biggest the biggest alignment of the
particular key with my query and that
query is which one is the subject of
course you're gonna train all these
queries and keys producing procedures so
this is this is a tension mechanism and
if you then want that that's where the
value comes in you can if if your
queries not only which ones the subject
but it's actually generically read that
okay I'm gonna extract some information
from some token that I'm going to use
later then you would actually take B say
aa B is the best one okay I'm gonna take
the value of B you're basically gonna
get a cab it a weighted average of the
values according to these values here
right so this is very shortly what
attention is if you if you want a
lengthy explanation go to the attention
is all you need video right so open that
I cheap T uses attention here and it's a
it's a left to right transformer that's
what it says here and what that means is
because also step-by-step but in each
step it uses attention so here is the
input tokens and as you can see it goes
in this direction so each one of these
and these are multiple layers of
attention so you can also layer these of
course so each one of the attention
intermediate steps can only attend to
whatever is to the left of it right you
can see this here so it goes step by
step and it goes left to right basically
so it can it can kind of take the
sequence in as a left to right input
basically what that means is whenever
you interpret a particular token you can
your context is only to the left of that
token you don't know what's coming in
it's like what do you when you read a
sentence from
left to right but then as humans
unconsciously we probably go and at the
end of the sentence kind of make sense
of the thing as a whole but here the
model is forced to make sense of what
the thing only from whatever is to the
left of it so that's a basic limitation
of these left to right models then there
is another approach which is called Elmo
which has been popular recently as a
substitute for word vectors so if you
know word vectors were vectors are
basically the kind of first stage in
most language processing tasks where for
each word say the cat sat something for
each word you have you had a big giant
table and for each word you associate a
vector of fixed size dimension right so
you place every word in a vector space
and these vectors you pre compute for
something like word Tyvek or glove and
that gives you a nice way to basically
deal with these words in a canonical way
and you can pre train the word vectors
that's all really nice but people have
realized ok words kind of multiple
meanings and words can kind of slightly
change meaning depending on words around
them and so on
so what Elmo does is Elmo uses to Alice
Tian's
one Elliston goes into this direction
when I Austin goes into this direction
and basically a single lsdm as we saw
the four it takes in the input sequence
one by one so here e1 and e2
if the en it produces hidden states at
each step produces a hidden state that
is a result of previous hidden state and
the current token and and then what it
says is ok now these hidden States here
basically these are now the embeddings
of the token here on e and so on right
these are the embeddings so the world
vectors as to say Oran are no longer
just one vector per word so they're not
in isolation anymore but basically you
need the entire sequence to compute the
word vectors as a result of this of this
Alice T and this is more powerful
because it can give individual words
multiple or each it basically each word
has kind of a unique and then depending
on the surrounding words you would still
hope that a given word would have
similar similar embedding or similar
word vector all across the language but
you can kind of fine tune it to the
particular sentence it is in and also
you can completely change its meaning if
it's if it's kind of a word that has a
completely new meaning in that sentence
so basically uses two LST M's one as as
I said here forward one backward these
also have multiple layers and so and
each of these produce one such hidden
vector per token and he would simply
concatenate the two from the from so
from here is this leather stain on the
left produces one disaster the right
produces maybe here another one and you
simply concatenate the two to get the
the final embedding the final word
vector for each token
so the fundamental limitation here is
that this is kind of you have
information from the left end you have
entered information from the right so
other than here the original transformer
you actually have you actually can
condition on the left context and the
right context but it's very it's it's
very shallow because it's simply a
concatenation of the left facing Alice
TM and the concatenation of the right
facing Alice TM and and these ultimately
intrinsically they have nothing to do
with each other they so you simply
concatenate the two things that the left
facing Ostiense still can only see to
the left and the right facing Alice team
still can only see to the right so you
basically have to
you have blind models and then you can
have concatenate so the it's still
suboptimal because what you want is you
want a single model to output your word
vectors or to interpret the language
that can look at both the left and the
right at the same time and then
incorporate information from both of
them simultaneously and not just at the
end by concatenation this is what Birth
does it's a bird here and this is kind
of what they claim is the new
contribution bird at each in each layer
here of the model D D let's look at this
and for a particular token they look at
all of the context so every every other
token in the in the input they look at
that and so the the basically it seems
kind of it seems kind of obvious but
it's it's actually there's there's
reasons why these other models don't do
this but so this is the entire point of
Berk is at each layer in this in this
transformer architecture is still an
attention that can ISM by the way so
that there's there's the mechanism of
attention here and and here is exactly
the same or almost the same they
actually keep it close on purpose in
order to compare but now we have
attention not only to the left but also
to the right to everything right so why
do these other model whether for example
the opening I transformer only look to
the left
that's because somehow you need a task
to train on right and most of the time
if you especially if you want
unsupervised training you going to do
something like language modeling and
language modeling what you have is a
sentence ABCD and you're asking what
comes next here alright so by by the
definition of the task you can only look
to the left
that's that's just how how these like
how the task works so it makes sense
that that these other models kind of do
this because they preach right and this
not Burt has a different free training
because they can they can only they have
to look to the left and the right and
the other thing is what you want to use
the model for so the good thing if you
own if you go left to right is you can
use the model now for generating
language in the same thing if if you
have a B C D and you ask and the model
is trying to produce the next character
only looking to the left right then you
can you can say what's the next
character the model says B and then we
can feed the same thing into the model
and say okay what's now the next
character what's now the next character
G so there's pretty useful if you only
look to the left you can actually use
the model then for generating a language
which is something you can't do with
Burt or it's not it's not really obvious
now how to do it with where people are I
know people are investigating into
language producing producing entire
sequences with Burt
but as yet it's not super clear how to
do this with this model that being said
them all is pretty good at pretty much
everything else so let's jump in to how
they train they train let's see here
they trained using masked basically
masked language modeling so when I
actually go into that first masked
language modeling what they do is they
basically replace some words by the mask
token and they don't have a good no nice
alright today I'm everyone here
all right here if you just look at kind
of the top sentence here the man went to
mask store
right don't don't don't worry about the
set and so on just this a man went to a
mask store and the models simply asked
to predict what's here which word is
there so it needs to incorporate
information from the right and from the
left to do this so that's basically how
you train it
they simply drop out some of the words
some of the time and they they have
different techniques so you can clearly
tell a lot of work has gone into kind of
fine-tuning everything in this model
like how to Train it and so on so let's
say we don't always do this sometimes we
do this other thing and sometimes we do
that and there's several ways of biasing
this model but basically you do this
mask which modeling and then because
they also want to evaluate on let's say
entire sequence tasks or tasks that span
multiple sentences what they do is the
second free training task at the same
time as you can see here where they feed
two sentences so that's the first
sentence that's the second sentence they
feed these two sentences as an input so
at first they have this token and these
separate the sentences and then they ask
the model to predict a label is next and
is next is neck is true if the second
sentence follows the first and so it's
if it's like a logical continuation and
the way you do this unsupervised is
really easy you take a big giant corpus
and you take a sentence for the first
sentence and then 50% of the time you
take the next sentence in the corpus and
the label is true and 50% of the time
you take some random sentence here you
say for example the man the man mask to
the store and the next sentence is
penguin mask or flightless birds and
that's kind of a random sentence so the
model is asked to predict well that's
probably not the next
and following this first sentence so you
do these two tasks a pre-trained and D
can do this unsupervised you don't need
supervised data for that you just need a
corpus and they do this for a long time
with a lot of data and the model itself
is giant has 24 I think of these
transformer layers so it's giant
and then you kind of pre-trained in this
model here is a here's an illustration
of some extra things so what they do is
they they first this is the input up
here so the first token is this CLS
token which is kind of the star token
and then this is the first sentence then
the step is the separator of two
sentences then this is the second
sentence and then again I said look up
to these hashtags in a second but first
they say okay first we have the token
embeddings so they kind of start with
with the original concept of word
vectors at the very basis because you
need to start with actually going into a
vector space to use these models but
they don't they they then then in kind
of transform these through the transform
layers they also use segments embeddings
and segments embeddings as you can see
here is simply a kind of a binary label
EI being the label for the first
sentence and E being the label for today
the second sentence so just the model
can differentiate which one's the first
which one's the second because it's kind
of hard to learn for a transformer
architecture that the tokens kind of
separate the sentences so you can want
to help it and the last thing is
positional embeddings and we've also
already talked about these in attention
is all you need this is where you can
kind of the model since it's a
transformer it doesn't go step by step
it doesn't go one of them
so it's kind of hard for the model to
make that how far things are apart from
each other
how far to tokens if they're neighbors
or if they're really far apart and these
positional embeddings kind of help the
model I decide if two tokens are close
to each other in input infer if they're
right they're just neighbors or if they
are actually really far apart all right
so this is this is how the kind of first
input is constructed out of these
embeddings and then it's fed through
these transformer layers as we saw with
the mask that lime task and his next
task I want to quickly get to these
hashtags what what they mean
so the input here is separated into word
pieces so called work pieces and what
that is is so in language processing
tasks you have kind of a choice you have
you have a choice of how to tokenize
your input so what let's look at a
sentence here subscribe to PewDiePie so
this is a sentence and the sentence is
rather let's say world wise complicated
so why matter language one will have
problem with this so first you need to
tokenize this sentence alright so what
most people do is they say okay here are
the word boundaries we're not tokenize
this into three segments first is
subscribe to piggyback okay so three
things and each of these now needs a a
word vector associated with it now to
the thing is the word vectors let's
assume you have them pre-trained or
something in any case you need a big
table a big big table and this goes down
here where for each word a the two I you
you have a
Keter associated with it right so you
need to keep this in your model and as
you can as you know English has a lot of
words here so this table is gonna be
really big and the problem is how do you
make this table right okay you could
make it kind of dynamically and so on
but in general you're gonna create this
table with all the words you know and
that's going to be too big because
English has so many words and then you
can say alright we'll only take the top
whatever is used in 90% of the language
which turns out to be it's kind of
burrito distributed so it turns out to
be like 5 percent of the words are used
in 90 percent of the language so you
just take these but then you're gonna
have the problem ok here 2 2 is not a
problem
why not 2 is used super often that we're
gonna have it at the very top somewhere
and we're gonna go back to it subscribe
is it's already it's not so common right
so maybe you have a word for it
somewhere down but then pewdiepie is a
name so there is no there's not even a
word like that's not even a word
it's it's just so what you what you
usually do what people usually do is
they have this out of vocabulary token
and then they have a vector associated
somewhere here without of vocabulary
token is a whatever I don't know what it
is I just don't like that I don't have
it in my vocabulary and the model kind
of deals that that's kind of it's not
it's not really ideal especially if you
don't want to generate language also
your model tends to generate out of
tabular tokens if you allow that if you
don't allow that you have a problem
during training so it's all kind of
messy what's the alternative the
alternative is to go character level so
let's look at character level in
character level you say all right my
words are obviously made of
actors and characters I'm just gonna
split it each character right here the
white space can be a character too so
I'm gonna split at each character and
then I'm simply going to have a bone
vector for each character and there's
only like 20-something six of those and
um so I can keep 26 vectors but this
tends to be rather problematic because a
character by itself having a meaning
that you know that can be encapsulated
by a vector is kind of its kind of shady
because the character character by
itself usually doesn't mean and it
doesn't have a meaning so what's the
solution here the solution is to go in
between the solution is to say well
let's actually go forward pieces and you
can kind of think of them as syllables
but you can you can split you can make
them in a way that you have a fixed size
vocabulary say okay I have 4,000 entry
places in my big table it's I can afford
4,000 size table so first of all I'm
going to have for each character ABCDE
and so on I'm going to have a vector but
then only have 26 have 3,000 some left
I'm going to have also the most common
words now a is already here but maybe I
can have two and from and so the most
common words they also get there and
then for the other things I'm going to
split the words maybe in a sub scribe
right so these are two syllables and sub
can be free kind of a prefix to many
things and I only need then 1 1 so I've
sub here sub I only need one vector for
that and then the rest if described
scribe is by the way also a word so I
can have that but if scribe weren't in
my vocabulary I can divide scribe Len up
into into characters and then describe
them with the
so basically I can mix and match here I
can sub it that's that I have that and
then scribe I don't have it I don't have
any of the pieces but so I can just use
the character the character so this
would would be sub and then s C or I II
so these these would be the tokens that
I work with now as as my input and this
these tags here so this is what would
happen to PewDiePie
you could simply split along each
character so you basic this kind of an
interpolation between the token model
and the character model and it's really
neat and it usually works quite well the
as I said the the hashtag sign here
simply means that these two have
original in one word and now this this
in here is just a word piece token this
is a really good example where where
where piece come in because play by
itself is a word and that can make play
yang instead of having an own vector for
that I can divide it into play which
already has a meaning and presumably
playing and play would have similar
meaning so it makes sense to have to
play as a so that's the token
singled-out
ear and then in as is as a suffix also
makes sense to have a token for that in
my table and then I said we have these
two tokens here and that probably
already gives me more information than
simply having the word playing right by
the way you should subscribe to
PewDiePie just FYI
alright let's go on so we we do
workpiece tokenization we do the masked
language model we do the next sentence
prediction pre-training what do we have
now we have a model that can really
really well
predict some masked words now how do we
use it
they evaluate on these I believe it's 11
tasks 11 different tasks of or is it I
don't know how many it is it is a lot
with the same model so this pre trend
model then how claim can be fine-tuned
to do all of these tasks and it gets up
it goes like state-of-the-art on
everyone it's crazy
so how do they fight in it so the
easiest tasks are the one are the
so-called sequence level tasks where you
basically have the sequence and you're
you're about to predict one class label
for the entire sequence so here where
the sentence pair classification tasks
for example the task we saw before the
is next task but there is more
sophisticated tasks that you need kind
of supervised data for and so with
supervised that you'd have a class level
that you trained on so what do you do is
let's look at one of them ever MN l I
they had it up here nope
here multi-genre natural language
inference crowd-sourced entailment
classification task so given a pair of
sentences the goal is to predict whether
the second sentence is an entailment
contradiction or neutral with respect to
the first one all right two sentences
and you're about to predict which one of
these three labels it is so you put the
two cent sentences here Burke can
already take two sentences as an input
as we saw right the the embeddings are
the the a and b embeddings and the
position of endings are left out of the
picture here but they would be added to
it and these these would be the
embeddings for it and then you pass this
through the verb monel and this is the
final layer and what they do is they
simply take now the the embedding the
final embedding for this first one
course
into this starter token and they simply
put a single layer of classification so
basically a logistic regression on it
and that's how they then get a class
label so if this is whatever let's say
this is this just gives you here a
hidden vector of 512 dimensions 512 and
you have three labels to output here 1 2
3 you simply need a a matrix that's 512
by 3 of size and these are the these are
the weights that you would then have to
train in addition the vert subvert is
pre trained and you have to simply only
now learn these weights of course they
also kind of fine-tune the entire vertol
but that's really fine-tuning the only
thing you have to learn from scratch is
is this these weights here that's pretty
first of all it's pretty neat because
you can be very quick at learning new
tasks because you simply start from the
pre-trade vert and then you go and learn
a single class for a layer on top and
astonishingly this works extremely well
for these tasks a bit of a a bit of a
more challenging task is this year squat
is a question-answering task and we're
gonna jump down here where they explain
the task so you have an input question
oops
you have an input question and then for
question is where the water droplets
collide with ice crystals to form
precipitation and you have an input
paragraph which is kind of a paragraph
from Wikipedia page and you know that
the answer is somewhere in this
paragraph right the data set is
constructed such that the answer is in
the paragraph so the entire referees
precipitation forms as small as smaller
droplets call ask the collision with
other raindrops
ice crystals within a cloud so you the
question is where do water droplets
collide perform precipitation the answer
here is within a cloud so that's this
this thing here so usually what squad
models do is they they predict the spam
they predict where it's the start of the
answer and where is the end of the
answer that's also what kind of birds
train to do so in order to do this what
you do is again you already have the
ability to input two sequences so we've
trained with two sentences but here they
say well you say oh well our first
sequence is going to be the question our
second sequence is going to be the
entire power paragraph from Wikipedia
and then for each output for each output
for the output of each token remember
there's as many outputs as there's
inputs because the transformer will
always transform to the same length of
sequence for each token in the output we
classify it is this token the start
token and or is this token the end token
or is this token none of all now what
they do effectively is that here each
each one outputs each one is a vector
and they as we said at the beginning of
finding out which ones the subject now
here we have two queries namely query
one which is is this to start let's call
it query s and query e is is this the
end token so these are two queries and
I'm going to just produce compute the
inner product of each query with each of
these outputs right and over my sequence
here this is gonna give me a
distribution so start for start maybe
this token is not much than this token
is a lot and so on the other solution
there's
I've tokens and for the end not so much
not so probable not so probable very
probable not suppose so what you get
when I get is from these inner products
is a distribution over which ones start
in which ones to end ok this one's
probably a start and this one's probably
the end so that's how you predict the
span and again what you have to
ultimately learn is these these queries
here and so not that much and this is
named entity recognition and named
entity recognition you have a sentence
and you're supposed to recognize named
entities like up here we saw subscribe
to PewDiePie and the named entity would
be PewDiePie
right this is a name and you're supposed
to recognize that this is a name and
they do it the same same way that they
do the squat basically or a similar way
sorry they basically for each of the
outputs here they simply classify
whether or not is it's part of an M
entity or not so what they have to do is
they have to simply train if they you
also have different labels for which
kind of entity is this this is like a
person and this is this is no entity so
if you have ten of the labels then each
for each thing you would classify it
into one of ten classes so you need a
classifier of input size versus number
of classes that's all you have to train
in addition to pre to fine-tuning vert
itself alright so they kind of evaluate
on all of these tasks they get super
duper numbers on all of them here burped
large
winds on pretty much everything and this
model is big just saying and they
trained it on TP use which is available
in kind of Google cloud infrastructure
so far they've trained it on a lot of
data so - - away it's it's kind of
expected that you would outperform but
it's very surprising that you outperform
everyone else by this much and they've
done a lot of kind of Appalachian
studies where they show that it's really
due to the fact that they do this left
and right context they they take into
account the left and right context of
given token when doing the the attention
that it's that that's why it's better so
here for example they compare the bird
base model and they say okay what if we
don't do the NSP the next sentence
prediction tasks then you can see the
numbers they already kind of they drop
on these tasks and what if we then
additionally do only left-to-right
training and the numbers they drop
really seriously again you see sometimes
here for example you see a pretty
serious drop in the number also here so
there really seems to be real value in
doing this kind of left and right
context attention so it's not just about
the model size and the amount of data
that's basically what they show here and
this is really cool that the paper
actually shows this because usually
people have an idea and they throw a lot
more resources at it and they're better
you never know why and this is pretty
cool that they actually show all right
so this is all I have to say about this
paper but check it out the models are
here pre-trained you can actually
download them you can find
Union for yourself for your own task and
they're pretty pretty powerful there are
smaller models for if you don't have TPU
that are also pre trained so check these
out as well and thanks a lot for us